du jazz un château un joli parc idée
vieille voiture ce week end la première
édition de l'art automobile dans le
cadre des journées du patrimoine a eu
lieu au château de brousse et à montfort
l'amaury l'idée c'est de présenter au
plus large public et pas nécessairement
public de connaisseurs concernant
l'automobile de collection
le fait que l'automobile peut avoir une
dimension patrimoniale puisque si on
remonte au début du 20e siècle qui sont
un petit peu les débuts de l'automobile
il y avait énormément d'artisans que ce
soit des celliers des carrossiers des
ingénieurs qui gérait la dimension
artisanale de l'automobile les
passionnés sont venus de toute la région
parisienne pour cette première
l'occasion pour eux de découvrir ou
redécouvrir des véhicules rares j'ai
remarqué le carré voisin est quand même
assez des voitures vraiment très rare
qu'on voit très peu
généralement l'occasion de concours
après moi à titre personnel j'ai une
préférence pour les facel vega j'ai
remarqué la face elles deux c'était une
bande dans un état exceptionnel autre
véhicule remarquable la reconstitution
de la voisin qui a battu le record du
monde de vitesse à l'autodrome de
montlhéry en 1927 sa voiture car
entièrement disparu et j'avais un moteur
c'est un moteur six cylindres titre avec
un pont arrière qui je suis et tiens ce
serait marrant de reconstruire ses deux
voitures qui a disparu complètement
donc on a dessiné la voiture d'après une
si cette photo un peu plus et après on
l'a reconstruite en l'espace d'un an et
demi c'était fait
au total 2000 personnes sont venues
admirer les véhicules anciens les
organisateurs pensent déjà à la seconde
édition qui devrait avoir lieu pendant
les journées du patrimoine l'année
prochaine